At
Ucla on telling you a story
because it's pretty damn easy.
So there's this neurological condition
virtually comprehensible.
What happens if you have any,
you,
you have a stroke in the right.
Uh,
the right priority area of your right hemisphere has,
it doesn't happen.
What happens if you have that stroke is you lose the lending side and the loss
is extremely interesting.
Firstly,
it gives you lose motor control so you can't move.
But that's really the beginning of it.
You lose your ability to conceptualize the fact that you had a left side of your
body and more.
You lose the ability to conceive and we don't know how this happens.
I think it must be something like if I stand here and look out at all of me,
I can see that people right in front of me quite clearly.
And then the people to my right and left tomes,
I keep my eyes big savings right in front of me.
They're quite blurry.
I can't see their faces on the way,
no other people.
And then by this are out at the periphery of my visual system.
I don't even have color vision anymore.
Even white tape it for the test showed that and then past that,
which is behind me.
There's nothing,
it's not black.
It's not an amputee,
it's just not there.
It's not even,
it's not even not fair.
It just doesn't exist.
And what seems to happen with people who have neglect that moves around the
three corners of everything instead of half.
Now that's a gap because we really don't know.
But if you get people who like to draw a claw,
they'll put all the numbers in one half and if can give you a plate full of
food,
they'll only eat the food on the right side of the plate.
And then if you turn the brake bill,
he half of what's left and then even more strangely now,
and then they notice that they have a left heart and it really upsets them.
So the,
and they noticed they have a left arm and they'll try to,
they'll be horrified by it.
They'll think in someone else's.
They'll think extremely someone that they know or that we did.
The nurses left the body and sometimes they'll even try to throw it out of bed
and so and so they don't seem to buy.
And here's the other thing,
strange strangers,
they're not upset about the fact that they're half paralyzed.
It's because they actually don't know that they're half parallax and the reason
for that specific part of the brain that would alert them to the fact that
they're half paralyzed as being destroyed by the stroke.
So it's,
it's they're not have sex at all white.
The apartment would make them upset because you should be upset if you lose half
your body.
It's like that's very upsetting.
And the fact that you get upset is your emergency to the importance of the loss.
And so imagine you can carry me a little bit.
Well then would you notice and answer as well?
We not.
And so what grandma Sean was experimented with the balance,
literally the balance of people who have neglected.
He did this weird little experiment that you do to test people's vestibular
system,
which enables them to stay on felons consultant.
If you pour cold water in someone's ear,
then it upstairs have sense of their balance because your ears are intensely
involved in your balance and your eyes are moving back and forth and it
destabilizes the seas.
And so around the Shaundra was testing his neglect patients for their,
for their,
uh,
their particular function using cold water.
A number of them woke up and realized that they were paralyzed.
And his idea was essentially that the shock,
eventually the shock of the cold water was enough to,
to increase,
say,
emotional functioning enough to reactivate the damage efforts in the right
hemisphere to wake them up enough to notice that half you're going,
he was missing.
Thank you.
Produce a catastrophic people show response when people realize what had
happened.
Um,
so if you call the attention of someone with neglect,
the left him say you have a left hand there and say,
can you move it?
And he'll say,
well,
never mind.
I don't feel like it hurt my arthritis is for you this morning.
It hurts me to come up with some rationalization for why they can't move it,
but they're upset.
So Robuchon none with irrigating for years and then they wake up and they have a
catastrophic emotional response to the loss of the live side of your body.
But then 20 minutes later they snap out of it and then they forget they lost the
left side.
They go right back to their old way of thinking.
And what's so interesting about this and how it's related to whatever he told
you is that sees their left hemisphere had already built a board with their body
and you know you haven't more than with your boy.
It's really BPL walk when you,
you can tell that magic if you break a tooth,
what happens if you break your tooth?
It's your tongue goes absolutely insane,
right?
Your next three months,
all your tongue is poke round in there.
Figure out exactly the contours of your problem and maybe it takes you three
months to update that too.
You don't feel like your bones is a stranger.
And the reason for that is,
well you should let him know which in your outright like clearing your mom just
unbelievably wide are not insensitive.
And so because why?
You put things in there and you have to eat and so you have the intelligence of
what's you and what isn't for you.
Choose your town like,
I mean it's very important to have that map that you see.
You see with your experience with having a damage tooth,
you see just how much work it takes to even do a little tiny bit of remapping,
right?
It's like three months of of Tom,
the effort to update your will over your mouth.
Imagine how much effort it would be lucky we'll take to update your model of
your body if you've lost half of it.
Right?
So that's it.
So your left hemisphere count do that keeps on process in your body with the old
model and since the right hemispheres damaged,
there isn't any emotions associated with the loss.
And so the left hemisphere just keeps on grinding away on its own logo on.
And that happens to us and walk like that's sort of how we think is that we have
these partial models of reality more or less work and were really stubborn about
and we don't want them to disappear because they take a bloody modern work to
formulate.
And if we're forced to lose the mega trends to be catastrophic.
And so an example of that might be,
you know,
let's say you put a whole bunch of effort into up monogamous,
monogamous relationship.
And so actually it's lasted 10 years.
What's the African?
Okay,
well the first PBS,
you've gone a lot of places with this person and that model claims with them.
You have a story and the story's based on your understanding of that person and
the implication of that understanding for your understanding of you.
So you know,
you might be,
well I took my,
my wife or husband to Hawaii and we had a nice time at God.
You have that whole memory and you have hundreds of memories like that.
All secrets to national story about who you are and where you are in the past.
And then you have a story like that about the present who you are now and then
give a story like that about your future.
And then you find out that your partner's been having sequential affairs for the
last 15 years and it's like,
well what happens all your models now in development?
And then you think,
well what does that mean exactly?
Well,
it doesn't just mean that you don't know who your partner is,
although we greeted means that it also means everything you thought about your
past isn't wrong.
All those memories of,
of everything that happened,
those aren't accurate.
And so when something like that happens in DC trail,
this is why Dante betrayers in the lowest level of hell,
by the way,
besides safety itself and chase Deniece,
this is the betrayers because it blows out your model up in the past and the
presence of the future.
You told me about where your are,
we don't know where you were and you don't know where you're going.
And it's worse than that because you also don't know who you are anymore because
you are obviously someone who just wasn't that awake and you were with Justin
wasn't who you thought they work.
And so it's no wonder you'd be resistant to information like that.
You know what I mean?
It's like who think out.
Once they have a global theory of that magnitude disprove that globe,
it just leaves you wide open and exposed to the world.
So we heard your tech,
your,
your theory is as much as you possibly can,
and I'm going to overthrow them because of some housing will disapprove pretty
to,
you know,
psychologists talk about that as confirmation bias.
Like Sam,
think about it as a cognitive that they no be moaning.
The fact that people are very stubborn about giving up their presuppositions,
but it's so bloody one little,
you know,
it's,
you put a lot of effort into that formulation of the world.
It's not just a representation,
right?
It's the way you live in the world.
And so when you give that up and then what the hell are you supposed to do?
Right?
You're supposed to be enraged.
He supposed to have a 50 supposed to become herbivorous.
Are you supposed to collapse into depression?
It's supposed to be like infinitely cynical.
Are you supposed to never have a relationship in your life?
Are you supposed to have complete contempt for yourself for being seen nine even
blind,
or you're supposed to hate you mad at him because it contains the capacity for
that kind of betrayal.
It's like you don't know.
All of those things are true all at one civil paisley,
and that's the little space that you occupy,
right?
That's the mythical underworld essentially.
That's a place you go when your dreams and hopes die.
Everyone goes there from time to time.
Lots of people go there and never come out.